welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and we have a new eternals trailer
that apparently dropped outside of new
rockstar's company time but i got some
frantic and very confusing messages from
our team to wake up and react to this i
honestly have no idea what to expect but
i'll react to it give you my initial
thoughts and then i will spend the rest
of today doing an in-depth frame by
frame breakdown that will come out
tomorrow on the channel this video is
sponsored by story blocks more on them
later but here we
go
of the universe
but the people of this planet brought
everyone back with a snap of a finger
yeah we did
the sudden return of the population
provided the necessary energy
for the emergence to begin
whoa
whoa
how long do we have
seven days
seven days
i should have woken up earlier damn
it we're eternals
woman of creation maybe we came here
7000 years ago
[Music]
to protect humans from the deviants
we were instructed not to interfere in
any human conflicts unless deviants are
involved
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
we need to find the others
i haven't seen some of them for
centuries
this is what the end of the world looks
like
at least we have front row seats
you know what's never saved the planet
you're sarcasm
[Music]
this looks amazing we have loved these
people since the day we arrived
really
when you love something and us
you protect it
[Music]
what am i looking at
you can't protect
any of them
oh my god
wow i bet you've built the perfect safe
house what's this even made of vibranium
nope
[Laughter]
fall collection
ikea
good god almighty this is a trailer this
is the eternals trailer we've been
waiting for right i mean nothing against
that previous teaser i guess it got me
excited it just kind of seemed like a
walk through a natural history museum
with an old 50s crooner hit in my
headphones the visuals of this movie
look incredible i wasn't really sure
even from the concept art how the
celestials were gonna look but here
chloe zhao accomplished this mix of
something that would look both tactile
but also kind of
an atmospheric experience the way that
in what if watching the watcher is just
kind of something that is in the sky and
in disguise now trust me when i say
making video content is time consuming
especially if you want that content to
be really high quality you know the type
of videos that people fall in love with
well storyblocks saves you time and
helps you make your videos that much
more lovable a storyblocks membership is
essential for any creator again thanks
to storyblocks for sponsoring this video
they have a huge library full of 4k and
hd footage after effects and premiere
pro templates music images and sound
effects to bring your stories to life
the assets are royalty free so you can
use your downloaded content anywhere for
commercial and personal use the
unlimited all access plan gives you
unlimited downloads for the over 1
million assets in their library choose a
plan that works for you from their
selection of flexible subscriptions at
scale to give you all the content and
tools you need to focus on creating not
worrying about budget storyblocks also
has this really cool new program the
restock initiative they are hiring
creators from marginalized communities
to create content that is more
reflective of the diverse world that we
live in go to storyblocks.com
new rockstars now or click the link in
the description to check out their plans
and get one for yourself okay so first
thing i want to talk about this
conversation between ajax and icarus
both of them eternals apparently 7 000
years old coming to the earth around
5000 bc which is interesting because
that's around the time recorded history
from early human civilizations began to
emerge but now ajax is describing how
the events of avengers in-game the
avengers going back in time recovering
each of the infinity stones and snapping
the dusted half of society back and not
just on earth all over the universe that
energy surge has created a kind of
divine disturbance causing what they're
calling the emergence which in this case
sounds like the re-awakening of the
deviants the monstrous lifelong enemies
of the eternals the beasts that the
eternals protect humans against and they
have seven days before the earth is
destroyed seven days having some
biblical significance according to the
book of genesis god created the earth in
seven days and according to the book of
eternals the celestials will destroy it
in the same amount of time i don't know
what exactly this spike of energy looks
like i imagine there's like some
thermometer somewhere in a mountain
right as hulk snapped all that rainbowy
energy went into it and made it go
[Music]
and then some rock pod just cracks
and then here comes a deviant like this
is why they don't let me direct the
movies maybe they should though okay so
this trailer answers the question and
does it in such a great way by having
the characters actually ask it of why
didn't the eternals help against thanos
why didn't the eternals intervene in any
past human war and i love the choice to
make the eternals watch because we did
have some theories that maybe they were
going to go the neil gaiman approach and
uh have the eternals memories wiped the
eternals didn't know they were eternals
they just thought that they were old and
alive for a really long time but this is
so much better it makes the eternals
suffer this heartbreak over watching the
people the creatures say love destroy
each other and be destroyed by other
forces and they're bound to not
intervene not by their own moral code
but by this commandment from the
celestials that the celestials probably
said if you even intervene in the
smallest way we will destroy the entire
planet it gives the eternals less power
over the situation but it also gives
them more relatability we feel bad for
them now and among these past wars we
see the burning of what looks like a
mesoamerican society you see those types
of pyramids as drig it looks like just
has to watch it all burn and then a
mushroom cloud that could be one of the
ones dropped over hiroshima or nagasaki
but the shot that blew my mind in this
trailer is this a glorious close-up of a
celestial and this looks like arishim
the judge because it's the red one
look there are a handful of different
celestials they all have like different
designs they have different functions
the one that we've seen in the mcu so
far is named issan the searcher who
showed up in the collector's story in
guardians of the galaxy but just by his
name being the judge means that he's the
one who bangs the gavel over the guilt
of earth and its uh people who live on
it is this place worth saving at the end
of the day now i broke down in a past
video the marvel family tree who kind of
created the known universe this movie is
saying the celestials were really the
group who did it technically in marvel
comics there is someone who created the
celestials even we won't go there here
but when you look at something like loki
it seems like those courts ruled over
everything with the timelines whereas
these guys supersede those courts even
all of creation as we know it there's
another shot of this erupting volcano
that we saw in the previous teaser this
is probably not vesuvius it looks like
it's on an island but one theory i had
is that this could be the continent of
atlantis or lemuria both of which were
sunken as part of a previous war that
involved the eternals and the deviants
and that the wars between them caused
this kind of seismic disaster that
caused a volcanic eruption that
destabilized and sunk the continent
under the sea i'm gonna have to go frame
by frame through these shots of cersei i
want to take my time with this there's a
lot of very inspired production design
and visuals i mean it's just like a
painting okay and another celestial shot
visible in this this green one this is
jamia the analyzer so i assume it works
with irishm to determine the metrics of
a planet's worthiness on whether or not
it is worth saving though in this case
it looks like he's kind of swirling
together an entire galaxy i do like in
this trailer how we apparently see that
moment of creation where the celestials
created the eternals by putting this
kind of glowing orb in their bodies
awakening them and then at one point we
see theena in the clutches of this looks
like a deviant now i believe this is
crow because in the comics xena has a
relationship with a deviant called crow
kind of a forbidden romance there and
it's kind of warning her as much as you
love these people you gotta let them go
you can't save them okay there's so much
to break down further from this trailer
i'm gonna take my time to do this frame
by frame forgive me as for your patience
as always and one way that you can help
support new rockstars directly is by
checking out all of our merch options at
new rockstarsmerch.com we have a new
what if inspired design called cosmic
witness it looks awesome and if you get
one of those you'll get the added option
to write in a custom shout out that will
appear at the bottom of our what if
after shows follow me at ea boss follow
me rockstar subscribe to rockstars for
more breakdowns of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
so
[Music]